hi everybody thank you for coming so my
name is Victor of you it's v I EU X on
Twitter IRC get help so if you have
questions after 52 to to reach me so I'm
one of the five guys working at the
ensign of Daka but tonight I will talk
about the whole platform so enjoying the
hub of what just what are the features
we launched recently and what would be
the future of those let's start by some
numbers so doc on its when we release
dokie away no was a month and a half ago
and since these states the numbers are
crazy so the number of ports on the hub
like doubled in months and a half so
it's crazy push and replace Joey's are
growing more than fifty percent up so
everybody is using docomo and more and
it's great because it's because of the
community that we can make such a great
product so it's tough that by white
seats new in the engine so what feature
did we did we did we added recently the
first one as of this afternoon we
finally moved the github repository from
the cloud organization to dokur so it
was a big change if you are contributor
you probably need to change your remotes
to the garage door care if you had open
request you may want to check them to
see if we either need rebates because we
had to change the odds of stuff in the
user code base I changed something we
wanted to do for a long time and we
finally took the time to do it so it's
also we merged doke up pose and don't
pose so that's two new commands to the
doctor she I that uses a sigil freezer
basically when you post a container it
will freeze the process inside this
container so there will be no memory
usage no cpu no I oh no so it's
completely freezed so pause and pose is
great and that's even more great it's
that we added the post automatically on
do commit so before when you did a
doctor committee of a running container
you could have some issues because we
were trying to save the container while
some files where of original stuff like
that no we had it to close automatically
so that's great trick you can you can
come into running container and it's
perfectly safe we also added some
network strategies so it's you use them
by using dash dash net on Doc I'll run
right now we are for networking strategy
but we have more more strategies are
becoming the first one it's a default
ones that we have since a long time it's
a bridge strategy so by default when you
start the document it will create a
bridge and each time you start a
container the container we have an IP on
this bridge attached to this bridge so
the entire container communication is
used through with this bridge so in this
strategy if you do if config inside the
container you see you you have of course
the loopback interface and also in your
eth0 interface you see the bridge an IP
Andrew bridge so starting by 172 so
that's the private address onions
abridge the other strategy is the host
networking so it was a huge feature
request also you can now put the whole
network stack of your host inside one
container so if you do a walk around
with dash dash not equal post
so if you host as much cheaper interface
you will see order interface in your
container so in this example you see all
still look back for the eth0 now I have
my my host IP by external external IP
and also I see the bridge I talk to are
here so you can do Thank You stuff the
host networking strategy is really great
because when you're our application in
container is really network consuming if
you put them in host networking there is
absolutely no overhead because there is
no bridge no not anything so yeah your
container speak directly to the host
interfaces and it it's really fast the
third one it's a really really powerful
so this prodigy allows you to share the
network stack of a container into
another one so a small example maybe
will be clear if you stop the container
that I I named see one based on the go
to image and I listen on my loopback
interface and the 480 I can stop another
container and say dash dash neji choir
container columned the first one and
then if I write on my loopback interface
on the second one it will appear on the
first container it's because both
container use the same look back
interface in the same network stack so
it's it's really great because it's it's
not the same usage but it's like host
there is no hover at all so if you want
to start on a radius container for
example you can use and 127 001 and your
content container you just use the same
network stack and then you can talk to
your Reggie's without any hovered so
that's a really really powerful feature
and the last strategy is much simpler I
just known to disable completely
networking in the container
you should configure see only only the
loopback interface so we have lots of
dogs around that and you can take a look
at the works but basically that's one of
the four strategies we have we also
mapped that docker ignore so it looks
like Kiki now so alongside your ducal
file you can have a dog nail file when
you can skip some directories a good
example in most of most of the times you
don't need the delicate with a folder
when you build so you can just put your
door kit for the inside gatinho and it
will be the dot when we blow the context
to the demon will be much faster we also
added the copy instruction in the docker
file so if you follow a bit get up and
the issues and everything you may know
that the odd we have it's it's difficult
because it has some magic inside it so
the basics was to add a file from your
context to your image but if you gather
you wear it with download it
automatically if you add a double it
will untie it and we had some issues at
some point you could change everything
so we had a copy instructions that do
only copy and that works great so if you
don't need all of those feature if you
don't need to download stuff from the
internet or and doubles or anything
please use copy when we merge the cop in
solution we updated all our dogs to put
copy instead of odd so yeah if you don't
need a basic code if you only need basic
copy please use copy because it it's
much better we also added tons of other
improvements changelog it's at the
bottom it's really long but just to
speak up some of them we we improve the
performance its stability a lot one of
our co worker christian did a great job
of on the trunk index for example so
that's the part in the codes that gave
you the
small random ideas you have a container
so it is a great job no it's much faster
and starting at terms of container are
is much faster then if you want let's
say the 10 last lines of your dog
dialogues before you had to go to the
old logs and some sort of shared stuff
though you can just tell your log with
the dash dash day we added two to the
dough Kellogg's command also you can
bind mount your your whole file system
into the container so it was a request
you so some people use it I know that
yeah now you can use / as a source of
your volume so it's possible we also
added features to some of the CLI
commands for like image for example you
can no toca image dash dash filter and
only display for example untagged images
so that's great when you want to clean
up your your Tokyo installation and
small all the other changes we added
fast we move so and document we had a
new flag to remove every container even
if the breed fade it removes the
container and we improve the testing
framework and the code coverage so it's
great because assisting those features I
think half of them were not developed by
dr. Inc was developed by the community
fosforito Kellogg's why developed other
communities filter also and that's great
because if you want to improve their
care just go to hit tab you be first I
starting to code you just write a nice
proposal so you asked before to see if
you have a chance to get me out and if
it's good you can just go ahead and and
yeah the community of their care is
really great we have lots of lots of
Korra questmiller every day that's
pretty great
so no its new in the hub so I'm an
ensign I'm in a giant team so I won't
get too much into details for the hub
but some guys want to help team are over
here so feel free to ask them questions
so first we introduced organizations and
groups great way to share your daughter
be lies between your co-workers so you
can either create an organization of or
if your company already had a docker
account you can come you can convert
your your user into an organization and
inside this organization you can create
groups like cure a group the deaf group
so that's that's really really useful
also we had a bit bucket support so git
and mercurial so you can note you can
now do an automated build from a bit big
feedback 8 30 stories at the same times
we announced private repositories and
private automated build so if you have a
private bitbucket account repositories
or private get a very boisterous you can
know matin make an automated build out
of it and it will be private so you can
you get one free private repo if you
sign in to have that doc outcome if you
want to try the feature it works really
great we also added official repository
so before we had like five or six
official repositories it was just
distribution like center I saw open to
all the beyond that was it now we have
official repository for supported
software do you have an official radius
image and we make this image we make
sure it works great and he has great
support and it's always up to date as
soon as reddit with radius will be
updated the official image will be
updated as well so if you need the
latest image go for this one because we
make those images thinking you will do
from
image or you will we use this image so
yeah if you if you need if you have the
official report you should really use
use this one and lastly we also added a
console to know when you log into the
knee to the hub at first you see the
state of your repositories you see the
number of pools and above stairs you
have really easily you also see like the
repository you start out of your
contributed and your activity feed so
this this concern it's your profile it's
everybody can see it you can see profile
from another user so it's great when you
want to know on what somebody is working
on pushing and pulling you can can take
a look at Jesus activity feed it it's
great well what will be next in the dog
and shine so I want to talk about some
features we already managed investor but
that we are not released our features
that will be major at some point first
it's a fine-grained control over our
capabilities so a couple we can say
total capabilities it's a set of TRL
actions for example other capabilities
code mkay note that if you have these
capabilities you can do an MK note you
can create a device if you don't have
this capabilities you can't so to do
containers and isolation by default
locale defines the white list of
capabilities that you can use and all of
all users are dropped that's one way of
two in containers we to do our dough
containers we use capabilities and
namespaces and see groups that yeah one
part is capabilities so before we had
only two choices the default whitest Oh
use dash dash privileged and it previous
mode you get all the capabilities so
it's free and secure and
we don't recommend to run in privileged
your projection server which cause
basically it's it's the same as being on
your host you don't have any
containerization or iteration in the
next three days we will introduce dash
dash cap add and drop to just add or
remove one kappa b GG just a few
examples the first one let's let's say
you want to change the status of one
network interface instead of using
desert privileged you just do kappahd
net admin and after you can do like ebay
link eth0 don't we work but yeah so
basically you can choose exactly what
you want and if you open if you want to
be I don't know more more secure or more
restrictive you could even remove
capabilities from the one we we put in
the white list so for example if you I
don't know why you want to do that but
if you want to remove the CH own prevent
any CH own on your container you can
just do cab drop cap ch1 and you will
have at the same container as usual but
without the CH own without the ability
to do a CH one you can combine all those
flags so if you want I don't know all
capabilities but you don't want to be
able to create your device you can just
to capture the equal pole and kept drop
empanadas and in that case we have every
single person cannot
those are future on to talk about peace
it's related it's around devices be
fellow so before you could use devices
if you were in privileged and if you
bind mount your device into your
container so with dodged a privilege and
dash V I don't know dev snd column Davis
and you you were able to use the devices
sound but again it was privileged it was
not recommended and not safe the next
one is we will add desert device flag so
basically the same way you did take your
own device and you put your audio device
and it you will be able to have the
device inside the container without
being privileged so that's two great
additions that allows you to do more
maltings with the inside dog a container
without having to be like privileged and
open to the world so it's great both of
those features are already measuring
master so for sure there will be in the
next release the next like wandered to
the third topic I want to talk about is
not much yet and not done completely
done yet but it will it will come soon
it's remote volume it's one of the
biggest issue we have on docker so today
our volumes work it's a bind mount so
when your client and your demon are on
the same machine it works great but if
if it's different machine it doesn't
work so if you have your client NY 6 and
your demon in book to each other in a vm
can't work that soon we will introduce
remote volumes so at first it will use
fuse you won't have to install anything
on your host it will be it will be
everything inside the client and the
server and it will be great it will
sorry Rach Rach fine so all of this
works star was started by a member of
the community at
around okok on and he finally gave us a
coat back to the basics so we are just
plug it plug in it together and it
should be out really soon if not in the
next three days I guess he will be the
in the in the next one I'm done do you
have some questions
yeah there we like any preliminary
announcement
actually
yeah there is no testing so in this URL
is this branch it's a working proof of
concept so it's not it's not done yet
because every volumes will be a fuse
even if on the same machines with still
use views but yeah it's working you can
try to use it and you can contribute
also for sure
okay nice so I was sitting on the front
row so i think i'll just talk since i
was sitting there before i get plugged
in i'm so my name is evan brown and i
work for amazon web services on the
elastic Beanstalk and cloud formation
teams so thanks to everyone a doctor for
having me over tonight I'm excited to
talk to you guys about a few things and
more importantly kind of do some demos
and take questions we will be sending
out an email I think sometime this week
to everyone with a fifty-dollar AWS
credit so kind of the stuff that we look
through if you haven't used AWS before
or even if you have you can apply to
your account and get going so